I’ve got a $20 bill here, I can buy stuff!
But, wait.
This is just a piece of paper.
Who says anyone will trust that this is worth $20?
Money is only useful if at least two people
agree that it can be trusted.
A new documentary asks,
what makes money trustworthy?
It has to be reliable, like a clock, says Steve Forbes.
It has to be fixed in value.
Sixty minutes in an hour;
sixty seconds in a minute.
Imagine if that floated each day,
that would make life chaotic.
So throughout history,
people needed a way to assign a fixed value to money.
The best mechanism for this would be some
kind of commodity that’s permanent,
easily transported, easily understood by everyone.
And that medium was, of course, gold.
Not “of course,” people have pegged money
to agricultural crops, or salt,
that's where we got the word “salary,”
but gold was more reliable.
And once it was accepted as currency
Money begins to create a kind of mobility
in people’s lives that they never had before.
But gold is heavy!
It’s hard to carry around.
That limited trade.
So people invented banks.
The Knights Templar developed a system where
they said, well, you can just deposit your
money here with us and then, when you need some,
you can withdraw it from your account.
This enabled the peasants to travel Europe
without being a danger of being robbed.
That enabled much more trade.
You could sell a bond in London,
and build a railroad in India.
And, as a result,
this seemingly resource poor
speck of Europe became the financial
center of the world.
Then, in the US Alexander Hamilton fixed
the dollar to gold.
The dollar became to be seen as a rock solid currency
where you could go anywhere in the world
and they would accept that dollar.
and the world boomed.
Wages soared.
It was an incredible period of wealth creation.
Don’t get me wrong, there were examples
of terrible deprivation and hunger.
But it was a time of great material progress.
And the monetary foundation of that progress
lay in the Gold Standard.
But as usual, rulers would debase the currency,
The Emperor Nero
They would call in all the coins,
melt them down, reissue them,
of course, with his picture on them.
But with less gold
Rome’s decline was very closely associated
with the decline of its money.
When you change the value of money,
you’re stealing property
That happened to Germany after WWI
To print money to pay for the conflict,
Europe and the U.S. went off gold.
And after losing the war,
Germany suffered the infamous Weimar hyperinflation.
We said to Germany,
“You have to pay back the world.”
The nation’s government certainly couldn’t
pay that much money.
So, Germany began to print and printed too much.
You go to a restaurant and you find that
your meal is going to cost eight thousand marks,
say, and you order it, you eat it,
and by the time the bill comes,
that eight thousand Marks
becomes sixteen thousand Marks.
In the United States, around that time,
politicians created our own crisis.
President Herbert Hoover signed into law
the Smoot Hawley Tariff.
Its sweeping taxes on thousands of foreign products
triggered a global trade war.
This set in motion events leading
to the Great Depression.
With millions unemployed,
governments searched for solutions.
They tightened the money
and the country literally ran out of money.
So, in some towns, there was no money left.
The bank closed.
I am going to establish a government market for gold.
Franklin Roosevelt,
in an attempt to revive a struggling US economy,
confiscated private holdings of gold
and devalued the dollar.
So, all kinds of constitutional freedoms
and this moral commitment to maintain the value
of the money were swept out
Roosevelt really didn’t know what to do.
so he kind of tried every theory,
the way people will do,
like a cook in a kitchen,
trying different spices.
Near the end of World War II,
Western governments met to try to stabilize currencies.
The world returned to gold-based money.
And it was enormously successful.
Those two decades, from 1950 to 1960,
were the most successful economically of any time.
But then, again,
a President abandoned the Gold Standard.
I directed Secretary Connelly
to suspend temporarily the convertibility of the dollar.
The value of the dollar plunged.
Since then the dollar lost
more than 80% of its value.
That’s one reason that today
Some believe the future lies in
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin.
Bitcoin is both a currency and a payment system,
so it’s like PayPal and U.S. dollars combined into one.
But so far, crypto-currencies’s price changes
make them hard to use as currency.
Can we transact with Bitcoin today?
Oh, I’ll pay you twenty Bitcoin
if you come to work for me.
That will be your annual salary.
Was it the Bitcoin that was worth 980
at the beginning of 2017?
Or, the Bitcoin that was worth 22,000 when 2018 began?
So what does the future hold?
Here’s the documentary’s concluding argument:
The only way to restore trust is for the United States
to return to the system
that worked for most of its history.
Gold has proven to be the preferred monetary standard.
These days, most economists oppose a gold standard.
Milton Friedman opposed it.
But this documentary will give you background
to help you decide what you think.
After all, we do need sound money with a stable value.
All this is the struggle for trust.
And money, ultimately, does depend on trust.
You can see the full documentary
on some PBS stations,
or stream it at: InMoneyWeTrust.org.